henri minutier bonjour
bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation dans la matinale de rtl
france alors on le disait dernier débat
hier soir entre les trois candidats à la
chancellerie allemande le spd et les
verts ont affiché leur rapprochement
c'est ce qu'on peut retenir ce matin est
ce que c'était prévisible comment
l'expliquer
eh bien je crois que la volonté de
coopérer de former un gouvernement
commun est très forte dans sa a été
rappelé et j'ai trouvé que les deux
partis ou les deux les deux candidats
cela me choque c'est madame m et puis
ont essayé de l'imiter et leurs
différences sont ceux là qui la question
climatique où on va dans bernanke a
rappelé que le spd est au pouvoir depuis
longtemps que finalement il n'a pas
encore fait beaucoup pour le pour le
climat mais sinon le temps était plutôt
à une sorte s'il est dansante de tacite
entre les deux partis les deux parties
alors olaf scholz en tête des sondages
ce matin en face le conservateur armin
laschet qui se considère comme
l'héritier naturel d'angela merkel est
ce qu'aujourd'hui il lui reste une
semaine et ce qu'il a encore deux le
temps de rattraper son retard
oui il peut bien sûr ce qui est
inquiétant c'est que le pratiquement
depuis la fin du mois d'août le spd est
toujours en tête que trois ou quatre
points d'avance cela dit comme vous
l'indiquez tout à l'heure il y à peu
près 40% de personnes qui ne savent pas
pour qui y est elles vont voter 2 donc
on ne sait pas comment ces personnes
avant finalement vers ont finalement
voté et il peut y avoir des
renversements haut pour le dernier cours
de la semaine mais en fait j'ai
l'impression que le la tendance de fond
est plutôt favorable le spd pour une
raison également très simple c'est que
après ces années de gouvernement deux
anglais merkel finalement les ânes les
allemands voudraient tourner la page et
voir autre chose vous vouliez un scrutin
particulier parce qu'il marque un la fin
de 16 années de pouvoir dans gala merkel
comment la chancelière allemande at elle
préparé sa succession finalement quand
on voit aujourd'hui les difficultés
d'armes ils n'achètent
convaincre est ce que l c'est
suffisamment investi selon vous
mais c'est sûr que ce qui lui est
reproché on peut pas dire qu'il y
beaucoup de chance pour préparer sa
succession
la présidente qui lui a succédé à la
tête de la cdo madame ce qu'on appelle à
kaka de la carène bawa a été obligé de
démissionner au bout d'aile au bout de
quelques mois et ensuite est arrivé donc
la chaîne qui ne convainc pas donc au
niveau de la direction du parti c'est
très très difficile pour pour la chaîne
notre passé de la première fois que les
chrétiens démocrates doivent affronter
une élection fédérale
sans avoir vu ses cinq sens que le
chancelier ceux des nouveaux candidats
d'habitude et il ya ce qu'on appelle
quand si leurs bonus c'est à dire comme
le chancelier sortant se présente ça
apporte des points supplémentaires en
crédibilité en autorité au parti
chrétien démocrate
cette fois ci madame merkel ne se
représente pas donc monsieur la chaîne
desserte du connu parce que dirige le
plus grand la plus grande des gens
d'allemagne la rhénanie du nord
westphalie mais c'est pas la même chose
que le diriger gouvernement fédéral dans
une situation est difficile pour la
céder ou de ses sous et comme je le
disais après ces années de gouvernement
prétend démocrate les allemands je
passais tout à fait normal souhaite
qu'il y ait un changement donc du coup
la présence d'ong et la marque elle-même
mardi prochain un meeting d'armes ils
l'achètent finalement ça va pas peser
grand chose selon vous
non je pense pas elle a déjà fait
quelques aussi je pense que les
chrétiens démocrates sont des comptes
que c'était une erreur de sa part n'est
pas intervenir davantage elle l'a fait
mais de façon extrêmement de façon
extrêmement limitées et les jeux sont
plus ou moins fait c'est pas parce
qu'elles interviendraient encore cette
semaine une fois que cela va a
fondamentalement changé les intentions
de vol lors d'autant plus qu'il ya une
particularité en allemagne qu'on ne
connaît pas du côté force et c'est le
fun par correspondance déjà une partie
importante des allemands je crois à peu
près un tiers ont voté par
correspondance en partie a
notamment en réseau si vous voulez des
réactions me pose la crise les crises
sanitaires donc si jean da et s'ils ont
suivi la tendance de fond que l'on voit
se dessiner depuis quelques semaines
c'est à dire le spd a fait de la vidéo à
quelques quelques points derrière on
peut penser que les choses sont un peu
reggae déjà et est ce que la perspective
d'une défaite de la cd ou en parallèle
ça ternit un peu le bilan d'angela
merkel
avait certainement serait-il tellement
mieux pour elle si c'est elle avait été
arrêtée démocrate qui prenait la
succession mais je pense que madame
merkel je sais très bien que finalement
il ya une usure des chrétiens démocrates
après seize années continue de le
gouvernement bon s'il a cédé ou perd le
pouvoir au niveau fédéral à la fin du
mois mais ce ne sera pas qu'elles
reçoivent pour ce que pour ceux pour ce
parti tout simplement parce que liliane
et régions la chesnaie vous est
fortement implantée sur le plan régional
elle gouverne à peu près la moitié des
länder des 16 länder en allemagne
fédérale donc il ya une possibilité de
ressourcement plus partie au niveau
fédéral on l'a très bien vu si vous
voulez on voit très bien que les elle
est très souvent les candidats à la
chancellerie où les fritures chancelier
sont les personnalités qui ont assumé
des responsabilités au niveau au niveau
régional donc n'oublions pas que
l'allemagne est un état fédéral et que
perdre le pouvoir au niveau fédéral
n'est pas nécessairement une une
catastrophe parce que les parties
peuvent continuer se régénérer au niveau
régional merci beaucoup on rimes étudié
pour votre éclairage ce matin sur rtl
france je le rappelle vous êtes
professeur honoraire à paris sorbonne
nouvelle et spécialiste de l'allemagne